members when i invite you to speak
please wait until there is a microphone
in front of you before speaking as
microphones are needed for the hearing
loop and for the audio recording
please use the active
anti-bacterial wipes if you do touch the
microphones
members
voting will be done on a show of hands
in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands for
then against recommendations and then
for abstaining
given the size of the room
and the numbers of us present
can i please ask that you put your hand
up clearly high in the air
so that it can be easily seen by all and
leave it up until i ask you to lower it
the normal rules of debate apply no
member should speak for longer than five
minutes and can i please ask you not to
repeat anything previously said
all those indicating to speak will be
given an opportunity to speak once
agenda item one apologies for absence
i have received
apologies in the office from councillor
carter
dre
lumley milne are there any more
apologies
councillor wilkinson
thank
you
councillor myers
thank you
that's it thank you
agenda item two
are there any declarations of interest
members
councillor foster
could you hold on a minute uh please
counselor foster we'll just get a
microphone to you
thank you
yes i'd like to declare non-pecuniary
interest as a member of two
organizations the recipients of
government covid grants via rdc
thank you
councillor foster please could you also
give the names of the organizations
marcus
rochford bowling club and the hockley
and hawkwell day centre thank you thank
you councillor foster
councillor sperrin
thank you chairman again a non-pecuniary
interest i'm involved with rayleigh
conservative club and they have also
received benefit from the kovic grunts
thank you councillor
okay thank you agenda item three
medium term
oh sorry i didn't
one moment please counselor
sorry you should never assume anything
should you but i had assumed that the
general council tax
dispensation would have applied to this
but if not i'd need to declare an
interest as well that
the company i own and work for received
a grant
of ten thousand pounds through the um
covid recovery
thank you council ahoy
okay so um i'm being advised that
thank you chairman members you do have a
general dispensation but for
transparency reasons if you wish to
declare you may say so
thank you angela
okay agenda item three
medium term financial strategy
2022-23 to 2026 to 27.
the leader of the council councillor
wootton will introduce the council's
budget
and
we will then invite portfolio holder for
financial services councillor
simon smith to present the report
councillor wootton
thank you very much
obligations
is
is
custodians and place makers of the
district over the next municipal year
this council will be exploring various
ways to further the opportunity to
support regeneration which will be
achieved in part through the delivery of
a new local plan which will give
priority to infrastructure being a
prerequisite to the delivery of new
homes built in the right place in our
district we have a policy to give
priority to development on brownfield
sites first
thus doing our best to protect the green
belt
this approach will assist in meeting
housing provision targets and to ensure
that current and future generations are
able to access high quality sustainable
homes and help stimulate the local
economy and employment opportunities for
our residents
this council has started this journey
with its own asset delivery programme
and will assist in enhancing employment
and residential space within our two
main towns
if the council can promote
opportunities for regeneration where the
commercial market may not bring forward
proposals independently then we will be
prepared to intervene this council will
look to bring forward proposals within
the next financial year that we've been
able to deliver on this ambition through
a programme of investment to make a
place-based difference to the lives of
all residents and businesses within the
rocha district
our business plan sets out the high
level priorities that the that as a
council we will work towards over the
medium term which are
being financially sustainable
we are continuing our transformation
journey through being a modern
accessible and financially sustainable
council
early intervention
we are working with partners through
early intervention facilitating safe
healthy and active communities
maximizing our assets we are playing our
part to develop a thriving economy
enhancing skills and employment
opportunities and maximizing use of the
council's own assets
and finally enabling communities we're
working with communities to protect
enhance and promote our district
despite the challenges faced over the
last year or two we have continued to
deliver excellent services to our
residents
some key achievements include supporting
businesses over the pandemic period we
have distributed well over 30 million
pounds of covered 19 grants to
businesses in the district and awarded
nearly 4 million pounds in additional
reliefs to ratepayers
we launched the reopening high street
safely safely and welcomed back
initiatives to support the safe
reopening of high streets following the
pandemic
supporting residents through early
intervention
between april and december 2021 135 new
affordable housing units were delivered
on strategic sites across the district
the council supported 47 residents to be
able to live more independently at home
and remove 97 housing hazards resulting
in an estimated saving of over half a
million pounds to the nhs and wider
society
the housing options service supported
over three thousand households to meet
their needs through services ranging
from advice
to provision of emergency accommodation
the council paid out over a quarter of a
million pounds intestine trace support
payments to low-income residents and 88
000 pounds in rent assistance
supporting the health and well-being of
residents
with the council's support fusion
lifestyle reopened both at clements hall
leisure center and raleigh leisure
center in a covid 19 secure phased
approach
with the total participation of nearly a
quarter of a million people between
april and december 2021 visiting the
places
the council facilitated events including
68 health walks in partnership with
walking for health and the ramblers with
over one and a half thousand
participants
supporting communities we achieved 50
match funding to invest 162 000 pounds
for investment in new play facilities
and recreation grounds across the
district
10 000 pounds of grants were awarded to
voluntary groups to enable them to
deliver initiatives that support the
joint rochford and castle point health
and well-being strategy
we launched a virtual tour of the rainy
windmill which retained its visit
england quality assured visitor
attraction accreditation
chairman and colleagues the list is end
this and goes beyond those long
established services we deal with as a
council day in and day out such as
development control waste collection
open space maintenance street cleaning
leisure services business support
housing community support car parking
management to name just but a few
the work started in 2021 which
culminated in january this year with an
agreement to work in partnership with
brentwood borough council in order to
deliver services through a shared
officer team
and is creative and will over time
deliver significant benefits
and not just financial and i do want to
emphasize that that happened in a very
very short period of time to come to a
very successful outcome
as a stakeholder in the south essex
ascella partnership we are making a
significant and very positive impact
directly and indirectly on the lives of
our residents
members
i do want us to give greater focus on
the work and actions this council is
doing to adapt to the effects of climate
change
and our commitment to be carbon neutral
by 2030 and i will be asking over the
next few months for us to commission a
report to set out exactly what we are
doing because i believe we are actually
doing a lot what we are failing to do is
to communicate that to our residents
i want to lead a council which is
creative and innovative a council with
opportunity a council with vision and
ambition all in the interests of the
communities we serve
the evidence is already there and
history speaks for itself the work the
council is able to achieve is
underpinned by sound financial strategic
financial planning and robust financial
management which our administration will
continue over the course of the next
final financial year and beyond
i will if i may madam chairman now hand
over to the portfolio holder for
financial services council simon smith
to outline the
2022-23 budget proposals in more detail
thank you madam chair thank you council
orton councillor simon smith members
with the chairman's commission i'll
speak from over here so that
you can see me
face rather than my back
i've got unfortunately quite a few words
members
i'm proud to present our
administration's medium-term financial
strategy to you tonight or in layman's
language our budget
the detail being in the 143 pages that
are in the report
as the leader has outlined the past 12
months have continued to be extremely
challenging
but nevertheless
rewarding in council achievements
i would like to thank the councillors
and officers who have worked hard to
present a balanced budget for your
approval
as well as working tirelessly to support
residents and businesses throughout the
last year
through a combination of prudent
financial management and additional
one-off support from the government we
are projecting to stay within budget
this financial year
this is a significant achievement in the
current climate
the council also continues to maintain
an unqualified set of financial accounts
and a value for money opinion from our
external auditors which have recently
been signed off for the 2021 financial
year
looking forward members will be aware
that the council is legally obliged to
set a balanced budget each year which
contains our service expand expenditure
from our available funding
the financial pressures arising from the
pandemic and the continued uncertainty
around future funding levels means that
this is an ongoing challenge
on medium-term projections anticipate a
gap of at least half a million pounds by
the end of this medium-term financial
strategy period and there are
significant risks that could add to this
gap
in that context we are putting forward a
responsible sustainable budget that will
help our economy to recover and will
protect and support our residents while
ensuring essential services continue to
be delivered
the press pressures on our budget in 22
23 total nearly 900 000 pounds
the council has worked hard to identify
cost reductions efficiency savings and
additional income to offset these
pressures leaving a gap of just 236
000 pounds
which brings me to council tax
this time of financial pressure for
residents we've carried out a
comprehensive exercise
to identify those efficiencies and cost
reductions across all of our service
areas but ensuring that the necessary
levels of expenditure are maintained for
the quality of services that we expect
to be delivered to our residents
therefore
i propose to affect announce effectively
what i did last year
that the council tax will rise by less
than ten pence a week
that's just around five pounds for a
whole year
equal to two point zero six percent and
those figures being for a band deep
property
it's only because the council manages
its finances well under a conservative
administration that we can continue to
deliver our services and support our
residents so effectively
we must take nothing for granted but
let's remind ourselves that as a council
that we've made consistently good
decisions to run a balanced budget and
that we are a council that has no debt
to service its day-to-day operation
last week council agreed a new council
tax support scheme
it was a new scheme but it was one that
guaranteed that no resident would be
worse off
however
i do know that from time to time
circumstances present themselves to
families and individuals that are very
challenging
for that we have a hardship fund
given the turmoil of recent times and in
anticipation of future adverse trends
we've increased the value of this
available fund to 15 000 pounds an
important safety net for our residents
twelve months ago we increased car
parking charges for the first time in
many years
behind the scenes we felt that going
forward that it would be better to have
small rises each year to help keep up
with inflation
and that's what we had intended to be
announcing this year
high streets of and commuting have still
not fully recovered and residents
pockets have been hit by inflation and
particularly higher fuel costs
we can't as a caring council be
insensitive to this
we must support where where we can so
because of our good and prudent
management of the fine council finances
we're in a position to announce that we
are not doing something
we are not going to increase car parking
charges
figuratively speaking they're going to
be parked for consideration again in 12
months time
it's not often that no news is good news
but it is this time car parking charges
are
frozen last year we announced the town
center regeneration fund of 50 000
pounds
to fund public space improvements to
attract visitors back to our town
centres
this fund not properly accessed in 2122
will be rolled over into 22-23
believe that we must do what we can
and continue to do what we can to
support regeneration in our town centres
after the covet pandemic
and this couldn't be better timing
i look forward to hearing about some of
the great projects over the coming year
similarly we had
we backed the importance of our
community safety fund and this year we
will be rolling this forward into 22 23
again topped up to a level of 100 000
pounds
to help safety measures investment in
safety measures across the district
the responses we received in our recent
budget survey showed that community
safety continues to be an area that
residents feel is particularly important
to them our residents spoke
we listened and were delivering
this year is the 70th celebration of her
majesty the queen's accession to the
throne
her platinum jubilee
in may and at various stages throughout
the year there will be celebrations
it only seems right that we as a council
support our residents joining in
celebrations
the 2021 budget survey also highlighted
the value residents place on their local
communities and the events that bring
communities closer together
i'm pleased to announce that with a
modest ten thousand pounds i'm able to
present to you the platinum purse
a fund that will be made available from
our reserves after our careful
management of finances
this will help to ensure that all
residents can have an opportunity to
join in celebrations for the platinum
jubilee in some form with our platinum
purse
council mike webb has just this evening
passed me a few more details that have
just been worked out
grants of up to 500 pounds will be made
available to applicants
they'll be looking to support a wide
range of events across the district
including those organized by local
church groups cubs scouts and of course
street parties
grants could you could be used for
things like food drink equipment bunting
small memorabilia given out to those
memorabilia to be given out to those
attending
we don't propose to have a complex
application process but we will be
asking applicants to use the
government's platinum jubilee website to
find out more about how to manage their
events through temporary road closures
raising money for charity and to
reference this on their application
forms
applications will be agreed by
councillor webb and the portfolio holder
for communities with officer support and
as part of the application process we'll
be asking for some feedback pictures and
short paragraphs from organizations that
ran events to evidence how the support
has helped them support help them to
enjoy their day
moving on to the proposed capital
programme
three years ago we launched our package
of playground refurbishments across the
district
at least one playground in every ward
was to have a refurbishment
it's true to say that the work did not
roll through as this at the desired rate
but there has been a global pandemic
that has could cause challenges to every
aspect of every everybody's life and
that includes playground refurbishments
i'm pleased to announce this year that
300 000 pounds will be allocated during
22 23 and that is just the start
we have in our long-term planning an
additional 50 000 pounds for each of the
included budgeting years denied
but what's more the scale of our
allocation and commitment stands as in
good stead for making further
applications for match funded grants and
money from other sources
we've done this in the past and we
should do it again
we've been successful in the past and
i'm sure we will be successful again
it's hard to predict funding
applications that are in the control of
others but over the next three years
investment could end up being as high as
000
750.000
750 000 pounds
and we must not lose sight of the
additional playgrounds that have been
delivered within some of the larger
housing schemes like boomwood hall and
west raleigh
but fantastic facilities are coming for
our younger residents
provision of over two million pounds has
been made within the proposed capital
programme for a significant investment
in vehicles to support the delivery of a
new waste contract in 2223 to ensure
these services can be delivered in a
modern and efficient way supporting the
council's wider business plans
the 22 23 capital and treasury
management strategy has been considered
by the review committee and is
recommended to paul council for approval
tonight there are one or two small
updates to the figures presented to
reflect the final capital programme
proposals
the experiences of the past
two years have highlighted the
importance of holding reasonable levels
of reserves to support us through times
of unexpected cost pressures pressures
the council's total level of earmarked
reserves remains at a level comparable
to similar local authorities and are not
considered to be excessive
particularly given the financial climate
of uncertainty that is faced over the
medium term
it is proposed that the 2223 news her
new homes bonus grant payment as well as
other one-off grants are transferred to
our investment our investment reserve to
fund future capital investment within
the district
the council continues to maintain a
general fund balance of at least one
million pounds or 10 percent of its net
revenue budget which is prudent to
maintain as a contingency for
emergencies
in support of the leaders of earlier
comments i reiterate that this council
looks forward to bringing forward
proposals within this next financial
year that will be able to deliver on the
our ambition of a programme of investor
gain within the district
tonight's budget does not set out the
details or provide individual business
cases but it does support the vision and
ambition this council has to make a
difference to the lives of our residents
and businesses in this place of our
rockford district
i've outlined challenges for the next
year
but i have also outlined lots of
exciting projects and actions that this
council is taking to service service
residents i'm convinced that we remain
in a strong position to meet these
challenges head on and our
administration will continue to advocate
for financial responsibility to ensure
the sustainability of the council over
the longer term
i therefore commend the medium-term
financial strategy to the council and
propose the recommendations set out at
section 17 of the report
thank you councillor
smith do you have a seconder
thank you councilor
members we have 13 recommendations moved
by councillor smith
um if you have any questions
oh sorry
councillor mason
that's mr mason
thank you madam chairman
warwickshire district residents decided
not to hold an alternative budget this
year
to save office a time
in the difficult circumstances that we
have all
experienced we are concerned with the
constant increases that this council has
put forward with the perceived
reductions in services
and the apparent failure
to hear
concerns expressed by residents
we are also aware of the increased
increasing costs
pressure to finances that our regis
residents face with mortgage increases
rent increases fuel and food costs
amongst other things despite the lengthy
speeches i feel that this budget is
inappropriate and unfortunately will not
be able to support it thank
you
thank you councilman
councillor wilkinson
madam chairman thank you
setting the council's annual budget is a
vitally important and legally required
part of the work of the finance team
in the council and i'd like to take this
opportunity to thank the section 151
officer and her staff along with the
portfolio holder for finance for the
continued work they provide in this area
of business
in preparation for this evening's budget
meeting and on the assumption that there
will be a move to raise council tax
again this year the independent group
met with a section 151 officer to look
at alternatives to raising council tax
i'm sure it is not lost on anyone in the
room just how much those most vulnerable
across our community are going to be
suffering in the continued months has
been mentioned a couple of times tonight
with a massive increase in energy prices
planned for later in the spring i cannot
and i will not support any move to
blindly raise taxes we're not the those
most vulnerable are sitting at home
making decisions about whether to put
the heating on or pay their taxes
equally
we have a statutory and a moral duty to
keep our council services working for
the residents that we serve
we become completely ineffective if we
can't provide the services we were set
up to provide and whilst the rise in
prices are affecting our residents it's
affecting the council too
so our plan was never to just press the
pause button on council tax
but to find a viable alternative that
protect the public and the council alike
council lawman and i came up with a plan
which would achieve just that baseline
advice from the section 151 officer
which would have protected the council
revenue income and protected those most
vulnerable in the district
a few days after presenting this plan to
the administration for consideration
we were informed that in fact we could
not do we wanted to do for a variety of
reasons and were provided with further
advice
sadly this rendered our idea unworkable
so we have withdrawn it and is no longer
on the table that said
i know that it did have some support
from within the administration and i'd
like to take this opportunity to thank
the conservative administration for at
least considering our proposals and the
positive comments that we received
regarding them
so that leaves us back at square one
again
i fully sympathise with any member who
cannot support council tax risers this
year however i would say two things
the revenue income of the council needs
to be protected also we have seen from
the reports presented by the section 151
officer that even after a 2.06 percent
rise
our residual gap remains close to half a
million pounds
the rise proposed this year will
generate approximately 162 000 pounds
the second thing is if you recognize the
above statement of being true then an
alternative solution has to be presented
to council for us to consider covering
that 162 000 pounds and bring the income
from elsewhere we've tried and we failed
in light of this and in absence of any
alternative proposal i will be offering
my support for the proposals before us
tonight as i believe this is the only
plan which can deliver what the council
needs to protect those services the
residents of this district whilst also
providing capital investment into our
district through high street investments
and community safety grant funds
madam chairman if i may be allowed one
further minute i have two questions
relating to the report with the report
which i have already afforded to the
leader and i would be grateful if either
the portfolio holder for finance or the
section one final officer 151 officer
could answer them for me at the end of
the mtfs strategy report presented the
members in appendix one
there is a list of each portfolio and
associated costs for each department
the first question is under human
resources there is an attendance bonus
of sixteen thousand nine hundred pounds
now i'm sure this is not simply a bonus
for staff attending work so i wonder if
he could explain what that is
second question is under the section
office accommodation rayleigh
there is a section called repairs
maintenance and utilities this has risen
from 10 000 pounds in 21 to 22 to 19 450
pounds and
whilst i do understand that a certain
amount of ongoing work needs to be done
to the civic suite to stop it from
falling apart
why are we spending the best part of 20
000 pounds on buildings which will
either be sold or potentially demolished
in the next few years thank you chairman
thank you councillor wilkinson um i
believe naomi campbell
lucas okay so the smith
thank you councillor wilkinson and uh
thank you for your due diligence and
going through all 143 pages and
uh
picking out a couple of good questions
um
in terms of your question with regard to
um appendix one
there there are non-contractual benefits
there are staff awards and that there is
an attendance award scheme in place and
i'll just read the extract from you
which is what has been funding
and the funding is
the additional funding is required to re
reflect lower sickness levels as many
people have worked at home during covert
19.
so the the element from the scheme is if
you attend 100 attendance during the
six-month period
you will receive an attendance award of
50 pounds or alternatively you may opt
for half a day's additional paid leave
with the attendance period being
first of april to 30th september and
first of mark october to 31st of march
so that is what that
allowance is for
with regard to um
the building's question
we have updated those budgets across the
board this year
um
the council has been regularly
struggling to meet the costs of doing
repairs and maintenance and there has
had to be a small draw on reserves to
fund these
one we fully accept the point that we're
trying to avoid these costs in future
through the asset delivery programme we
do have to continue to keep our public
buildings open or closed safe and secure
in the meantime until a firm decision is
made by the council at the relevant stop
go point thank you thank you councillor
smith
councillor newport
you chairman
um
i didn't really prepare a speech because
we've heard lots of uh wonderful things
from the portfolio holder
um
um one of the things that we heard about
was a i think was a ten thousand pound
fund for
eat drink and be merry
i was um
quite shocked
this um in recent weeks to receive an
email
from the nhs
which was the fact that rdc wished to
charge them to park the breast screening
unit
um in one of the car parks
around 3000 pounds for six months
so what i would like to propose to the
leader
is that in the schedule of fees
that
that fee
um
we basically make the nhs breast
screening unit exempt from any fees for
parking
i think
listening to the speeches tonight
everything we heard about was about
caring
looking after our residents
i think the
ladies
in our community
who would be disproportionately affected
by this
terrible cancer
should be afforded the modest
cost of
parking for the unit
so i would like the leader to commit to
that tonight thank you
thank you councillor newport
councillor are you able to answer that
this evening
thank you madam chairman um
i have to confess that i feel marginally
uncomfortable about the charges that are
level levied um this does actually get
covered in a separate report that comes
out on our fees and charges and what i
will commit to councillor newport to do
is to review it i don't particularly
want to make a firm decision tonight
without considering the
various angles but uh i think he makes a
fair point um these things always become
uh very um you know we always want to do
the right thing in terms of
our residents and i will commit to
council in newport that we will review
that and
give it
urgent consideration thank you madam
chairman thank you council orton
councillor hi
did you wish to speak
thank you chairman
very loud there
um
as always i've read the budget i'd like
to um thank naomi lucas for all the hard
work she puts in i might not necessarily
necessarily agree with the budget but i
understand the work that goes into it
i'd also like to thank naomi for
responding to my questions today which
just helped me clear up a few points i
wanted to say tonight
um
i will come to councillor newport
suggestions at the end as i'm sure
you're aware i probably have something
something i'd like to say on this as
well um
but i'd like to start with a budget i've
i sat through essex's budget last week
or the week before and i felt that
budget had
a vision to it
i might not agree with it i voted
against it but it had a vision it had
the leader's vision
for what he wanted to do
and the conservative party wanted to do
in essex i agree with some of it but not
enough of it um i just feel this lacks
that overarching vision for the district
um
and i think that's partly because our
business plan is still
a pre-covered business plan i know it's
2020 but it's still not taken account of
what has changed i think we desperately
need to update the business plan when we
did the business plan we were told it's
a live document it's still the same
document as it was in 2020 when it was
revised and i think we really need to do
that and to keep it live and to keep it
moving forward
um and i hope that's
taken in the way it's meant it's not
meant as a massive criticism just we'd
like to do that
thing i would
i'm quite angry about this
i thank councillor wooten for actually
mentioning
climate and he mentioned climate change
i would rather it was climate
breakdown if you do a word search in
this budget
climate is mentioned once and that's
about the financial climate it's not
about our climate
we have a
we are supposed to be aiming for climate
carbon neutrality within the council by
2030 but it is just not mentioned here
at all
and there's no budget there's no there's
no
reserves in relation to it
i understand that the working group is
meeting
i have no idea is what what is happening
there
i find it
i cannot find the words to understand
why you haven't put climate into this
budget or into the mtfs you really need
to work harder on this
as the administration it's not good
enough just to have the words
you need to do it and i know there's
members on in the certified i know our
chairman is very hot on this i know
councillor joe mcpherson is very hot on
this and i'm sure others are as well and
i just wish our voices could be heard
more within the administration because i
think this is something we are missing
we're missing it badly and i would like
to see that and i hope
councilwoman as he suggested in the next
few months this will come forward i will
be asking questions at the next council
meeting on it because i know we should
have there are things we should have
done and i do not believe they have yet
been done
i'll move on from climate now
i've mentioned about the budget i won't
go into detail
i
i believe along with um councillor
mrs mason that
it's very hard for our residents at the
moment and i'm just going to propose one
amendment to the budget
which is to fund the budget gap
of 162 000 pounds
from reserves
just for some information and i know
what's going to be said to me that you
we need reserves
reserves are supposedly
ten percent of our expected spend which
is one million pounds or one million and
forty five thousand i think it is
um that's ten percent our reserves are
actually one point four million they're
fourteen percent
i think that is very high
i don't think we need to have 14
reserves if you
take 162 000 pounds
away from 1.4 million it comes to 1.3
million
that's still 12 and a half percent of
our expected spend it's still above the
minimum and i think this is perfectly
affordable for this council i think
this year we should
help our residents by delaying as far as
as long as possible any rise that has to
be put in we could put a rise in next
year if it is desperately needed
um so that's that amendment i would just
like to
quickly touch on what councillor newport
said
um
i may find this difficult
but i do know that
diane had queried this before
she had queried to the meeting after she
had been diagnosed for those who don't
know diane was diagnosed with breast
cancer in a
in a portable unit in a car park
council ahoy i'm really sure you are
running out i would very much like
councillor wooden to review this
properly
and to take that take that charge away
thank you
thank you
councillor wooten would you like to come
back on there
thank you madam chairman uh i think i've
already provided a comprehensive answer
in respect of the breast screening unit
uh it is an emotive subject
it's on the subject that i understand
but
i've given a promise already so i won't
go over that point again and in terms of
the vision of this administration i find
it absolutely amazing because what have
we done over the last year
we have clearly cemented our position
with a seller which is about working
with south essex local authorities
we've established a fantastic
opportunity working with brentwood
council uh all the opportunities that
that provides by working collaboratively
with
councilman mr mason
i believe that you said we could only
have one speech
and you're allowing another one for the
leader of the council so i've got no
objection thank you thank you councillor
mrs mason
councillor wootton is responding to
councillor hoy's question
please continue councillor woodton thank
you madam chairman exactly that i am
responding to the questions
in terms of the vision that was set out
there were a number of items within the
programme set forward under the
brentwood partnership which provide
vision for this authority
and
the portfolio holder for finance spoke
about playgrounds opportunities for our
really young people no cuts in service i
heard that mentioned earlier talking
about cutscene service where are the
cuts in service quite the reverse
actually we're expanding services
a hundred thousand pounds being spent on
community safety fifteen thousand pound
being spent on hardship fund ten
thousand pounds to celebrate her majesty
the queen i don't know where this lacks
vision i really don't mad at madam
chairman and i just think dare i say it
is a political speech rather than a
reality speech thank you thank you
councillorton
[Applause]
okay uh before we move on uh
councillor hoy you proposed an amendment
are you do you have a second her
councillor mrs mason
we are now speaking to the amendment
council ohio are you able to repeat the
amendment please
yes thank you chairman i'll just keep to
the
amendment that the
budget gap of 162 000 pounds
for which the precept is increasing by
2.06 percent for
is funded by transfer of from reserves
of 162 thousand pounds
i'm remember sorry did that make sense
um
that
instead of increasing the precept by
2.06 percent the funding gap of 162 000
pounds
is funded by a transfer out of his
general reserves
have you have you got all that
information
um
thank you chair can you hear me yeah
um yeah i think thank you i think i
understand the amendment as um
council hawaii sets out which is to
keep council tax at their current levels
rather than raise them by the proposed
amount and instead to fund that from
general balances and before members um
consider that further i'd just like to
point out that um
in that scenario the gap would still um
the funding gap would still exist in
future years it would just be deferring
the um gap for another year so we could
fund it from one-off um means for this
financial year um but it would just add
to the gap from next year onwards so
that 162 000 pounds gap would still
exist so it doesn't actually solve the
long-term problem it would just defer it
for
another year
yeah sorry i'm not meaning to buy i just
wanted to i just wanted office sorry i
just wanted members to be clear on the
impact and just before you i'm not i'm
not um advocating one way or the other i
just wanted to be clear that it was a an
ongoing it would create an ongoing gap
not that it wouldn't fix it permanently
i will now take questions from the floor
counsellor
simon smith
thank you chairman
i don't look to support
this amendment
this is effectively kicking a problem
down the road we have presented to
members tonight a balanced
sustainable
budget that considers
our needs to deliver services and our
ability to deliver services
are
not cutting services
and
i'm not able to
take what i consider to be
a a slightly
backward step
backward looking step in administering
the council finances by simply dealing
with a budget gap
by by spending reserves
thank you councillor smith
councillor mrs mason
thank you
madam chairman
yes it is deferring it
but we are in exceptional times and in
exceptional times you don't normally
make anything other than prudent moves
as councillor hoy has pointed out our
reserves are at 14
when the recommended minimum is 10
doing this this move which not only
would help every resident in the
district every single person
including those that are struggling at
the moment and those are likely to
struggle more when this if this
original budget is passed we would still
have reserves of 12 and a half percent
it's
not a difficult sum to do there's
nothing wrong sometimes with postponing
something when you're helping people and
i do hope
that this is not a political statement
this is to help our residents and i hope
that the administration will take that
in the manner that it is meant thank you
councillor fd
thank you um
i agree with the sentiment of not
raising the
of not giving raising the council tax
but
again this seems to be brought up every
year i can't remember last year but i
remember the cast couple of years before
that this was brought up with funding
the budget gap from reserves
and we've got money to spend from
reserves we've got waste vehicles to buy
we've got um
factors that could come into this
and
i can't support
this amendment
i'm very sorry so
thank you
thank you councillor fd
are there any more questions
okay so
if we'd like to take this to the vote
then those in favor
of the amendment
oh yes of course sorry counselor hi
thank you chairman i will be brief
um
i'll just
just keep to one comment um i think it
was just council after you spoke i
couldn't quite see that far um
yes it does come every year our reserves
go up every year as well that suggests
to me that we don't really need to do
the increase every year thank you
without no further ado we'll go for the
vote then those in favor of the
amendment please raise your hand
foreign
uh we'll just finish the vote first have
you got those numbers first on you
please lower your hand those against
the champions
thank you you can lower your hands and
those abstaining please
thank you
members that amendment was 9 4 the
amendment 23 against and
one abstention
is that the right number
wilkinson
so that was 9 4 22 against and one
abstention
um if
if you could raise your hand for those
that wanted
recorded votes please
might not be brilliant but 9
and 22
is 31.
one abstention
is 32.
five apologies
is 37. i thought we had 38 members
i could be wrong there could be someone
else absolutely those six apologies
thank you they are recorded
we will now move on to the
recommendations
apologies counselor web
thank
you i'd like to thank the portfolio
holder for fire finance councillor simon
smith for delivering an another
excellent and balanced budget
there's a couple of highlights that i'd
just like to remind members of the
increase in the hardship fund which is
going up to 15 000 pounds a welcome
support to the most vulnerable families
in our community
with frozen car parking charges this
year
supporting local businesses and high
streets
another welcome move and thanks again to
the portfolio holder for finance for
that
in addition to that we'll be seeing
another 300 000 pounds invested in our
playgrounds helping out our children and
families again a welcome addition
i would also like to thank the portfolio
holder for agreeing to the platinum
purse as you know this is a fantastic
anniversary to celebrate the 70th
anniversary of the queen coming to the
throne and it gives us an opportunity to
celebrate that within our communities
the district has a fantastic community
spirit
and this grant will help to support our
communities as they come together to
celebrate this event i look forward to
the applications coming forward from
various community groups
residence groups cubs and scouts groups
to celebrate a unique event in the life
of the district
and i'm thankful that our district will
be able to support our communities in
doing that
so once again my support for this budget
and thank you to the portfolio holder
for some excellent suggestions in there
thank you
thank you councillor webb councillor
foster thank you madam chairman i was
going to make that speech but i just
want to add something to it
it's a word of thanks to the officers on
behalf of the two organizations i
mentioned earlier for the rapid
distribution
of the kovitz support grants have been
really important and helpful thank you
thank you councillor foster
councillor smith
okay are there any
other people that wishing to speak
okay councillor smith
um i'll be very brief because there's a
lot of words been spoken tonight
just to remind members that
this is a good budget
i believe this to be a good budget a
considered budget a budget that has had
a lot of hard work gone into it
it advocates our financial
responsibility to ensure the
sustainability of the council and there
are many aspects to it that will allow
our residents to benefit
and just one small
point on the platinum purse that
councillor newport
didn't like too much can i remind
council newport that it was only january
where he was considering floating an
idea on facebook of giving
residents in rayleigh a 50 pound gift
card which would literally have been
giving away
1.5 million pounds of the council's
money
so
a modest 10 000 pounds
to allow
residents around the district councillor
smith please have you just listened to
the point of order
point score in exercise against me
and
the fact of a 50 pound gift card i think
he's taking it out of context i think i
was merely pointing to
another country where they did offer
that so thank you your point of order is
i simply described floating of an idea
um
so so without without any further ado
i
recommend
this report
i recommend our budget to council thank
you
thank you councillor smith
i would like to ask the members now to
vote those uh first of all i'll read out
the recommendations
as moved by councillor smith
and seconded by councillor wootton
they're set out on paragraph 17.1 on
pages 3.24 and 3.25 of the report
that the net revenue budget requirement
for 2022-23
is set out at 9.7
10 million
paragraph
as per as paragraph 720
uh item two that the council program for
2022-23
set out at appendix 2 be approved and
the forecast for the years 2023 24
to 20 26 27 be noted
that the section 151 officer be
authorized to adjust capital projects
budgets in 2022-2023
do you have a point of order council
mason
the
recommendations and i will then explain
thank you
the section 151 officer be authorized to
adjust capital project budgets in 2023
20 2022 to 2023
after the
2021-22 accounts are closed and the
amount of slippage and budget carried
forward required are confirmed
that it be noted that the proposed
council tax requirement for the
council's own purposes
excluding parish and town councils and
precepts for
2022-23 is 8.019
million as per paragraph 7.20
item 5
that the 2022 to 23 band d equivalent
tax base
for the purpose of determining the
council tax charge
is agreed
as 32
million
707.6 properties
item 6
that the increase in rochford district
council tax of 4 pound 95
that's
2.06 percent
for 20 22 23
is approved by recorded vote
that the schedule of fees and charges
for 2022-23
is set out in appendix 3 is approved
item 8 that the target
minimum general balance as at the 1st of
april 2023
is set out at 1 million
item 9
that the expected earmarked reserves
position set out in section 14 is noted
item 10
that's the statement on the robustness
of the estimates and reserves that
section 14 is noted
item 11 that the equality impact
assessment as set out in section 12 of
this report is noted
item 12 that the capital and treasury
marriage management strategy for 2022-23
has set out in appendix 4
including the 2022-23
prudential indicators is approved
item 13
that the budget consultation report at
appendix 5 be noted
members the recommendations 4
9
10
11
and 13
are for noting are these noted members
thank you
0.5
yes thank you for that councillor fd 32
707.6 properties thank you
councillor mrs mason
i think you said item four it's not it's
item two
so if you're going to back them together
can you just clarify that
the ones for noting on my
documents are 2
10 11 and 13. and i'm happy to accept
no there's four as well
thank you very much
yeah and two
chairman um our recommendation two is
that the capital programme for 2022-23
set out an appendix to be approved
and the forecast of the year is 22 sorry
20 23 24
to 26 27 be noted so that will be taken
as a
a vote
so item two will be taken as a vote so
we'll go back to the numbers that i
originally read out
which are
recommendations for
4
9 10 11 and 13 are for noting members is
that noted
thank you
members recommendation six relating to
the proposed increase in council tax
must be determined by a recorded vote
i would suggest that we take the
recorded vote on this now
when sonia calls out your name
can you please indicate whether you are
wishing to vote for
or against the motion or if you wish to
abstain
sonia
councillor mrs butcher
counselor mrs carter
councillor constable
councillor fd
councillor eves
councillor foster
councillor mrs gadsden
councillor mr gooding
councillor mrs gooding
for councillor hazelwood
councillor hoy
councillor mrs knight
against
council mrs mason
councillor merrick
councilor myers
councillor james newport
councillor
mrs newport
councillor mrs pavlin
councillor mrs rowe
and mrs shaw
counselor mr shaw
answer smith
answers sparing
councillor stanley
councillor steptoe
council award
councillor webb
cancer mrs weston
hansa wilkinson
councillor williams
councillor wilson
councillor wootton
two three four members that was 23 4
9 against and no abstentions
that vote is carried
members we're now left with
recommendations one
two
three
five
seven
eight
and twelve
are you happy to vote on these all
together
if you i will assume you are unless you
raise your hand
okay we'll take those separately
okay
recommendation one
that the net revenue budget requirement
for 2022 23 is set out at
9.710 million as par as per paragraph
720
those in favor
please raise your hands
please lower your hands
those against please raise your hands
thank you please lower your hands are
there any abstentions
there are 23 4
7 against and two abstentions so that
motion is carried we will now move on to
item two that the capital
program for 2223
set out in appendix to be approved and
the forecast for the years 20 23 24 to
20 26 27
be noted
members those that are four please raise
your hands
closed captioning
thank you members you know right lower
your hand
those members against
please raise your hands
and are there any abstentions thank you
two
so that is 23 4
7 against and two abstentions
that is carried thank you
we're now going on to the item three
that the section 151 officer be
authorized
to adjust capital project budgets in
2022-23
after the
2021-22 accounts are closed and the
amounts of slippage and budget carry
forward required are confirmed
those in favor please raise your hand
please lower your hands
those against please raise your hands
oh she's unanimous thank you
so that's recommendation 4 is carried
recommendation five
that the
2022-23 band d equivalent tax base for
the purposes of determining the council
tax charge is agreed at 32
700
properties
those in favor please raise your hands
that is unanimous and carried
item 7 that the schedule of fees and
charges for 2022-23
set out in appendix 3 is approved those
in favor please raise your hands
24.
those please lower your hands those
against please raise your hands
and those extensions please raise your
hands
thank you members please lower your
hands
members that's 24 4
one against and four abstentions
that is
carried item eight that the target
minimum general balance as at the first
of april of 2023
is set at 1 million
members those in favor please raise your
hand
thank you members please lower your hand
that is unanimous and carried
we are now on item 12
that the capital and treasury management
strategy for 2022-23
as set out in appendix 4
including the
2022-23 prudential indicators is
approved
those in favor please raise your hand
please lower your hand
those against please raise your hands
and those absolutely please raise your
hands
members that's 22 4
0 against and eight abstentions
and that
we need a microphone
thank you madam speaker it's just a
matter of clarification
it's on item two that i believe was
excluded from the noted uh because
councillor mrs mason
uh
noted that item
and um she wanted it
so it was going to be an approved item
was that item noted at all because it
was excluded
from the original count
thank you council award it was approved
and noted thank you
okay just wanted to clarify that because
it was excluded from the noted section
thank you
thank you that was approved
okay
item four on the agenda
setting the council tax 2022-23
members before i introduce this
item can i draw your attention to the
fact that although there were some
formatting issues with the committee
report these were minor ones primarily
affecting spacing between the words the
actual financials in the report are not
affected
councillor smith portfolio holder for
financial services will now introduce
the report thank you
thank you chairman
as outlined in the previous budget
report the pressures under which local
government operate remain significant
and this authority continues to look
closely at opportunities to make
efficiency savings and generate new
sources of revenue
this is not only in response to the
removal of government grants but is also
to deal with significant cost increases
arising from inflationary councillor
smith um they can't hear you is your mic
off
[Music]
do you wish me to start again
yes please okay
as outlined in the budget reporter
in the previous item the pressures under
which the local government
uh opera under which local government
operates remains significant and this
authority continues to look closely at
opportunities to make efficiency savings
and to generate new sources of revenue
this is not only in response to the
removal of government grants but is to
deal with significant cost increases
arising from inflationary and
demographic pressures as well as the
impact of covid 19.
as a responsible council we will
continue to look at areas where costs
can be reduced
or income generated
however in 2223 there is a need to
increase council tax by just under 2.1
percent to help fund the financial
pressures that the district is facing
this equates to an increase of less than
10 pence per household per week on a
banned d property
the proposal is to set rochford
districts rochford districts council
tax
rush for district councils council tax
sorry for a band d property at
245 pounds 16 pence per year
the overall breakdown of the annual
council tax for a band d property would
be
essex county council
1231 pounds 65 pence
essex county council and social care
levy
169 pounds 47 pence
essex county fire and rescue 75 pounds
and 33 pence
essex police fire and crime commissioner
218 pounds 52 pence
the average of parish and town councils
53 pounds and 84 pence and rochford
district council 245 pounds 16 pence
the average total council tax for a band
d property for 22 23 would be
1993 pounds 97 pence
an increase of 78 pounds 18 pence that
equates to 4.1 percent
it needs to be remembered that
rochford's district council only keeps a
small proportion of that total council
tax that it collects across the district
with the majority going to essex county
council as well as the fire police and
parish councils
in conclusion chairman although these
remain difficult financial times
rochford district council remains
committed to providing excellent
services to our residents and partners
with this in mind we will be doing all
we can to deliver innovative and high
quality services
chairman i commend the rocha district
council council's tax to members for
approval as set out in the
recommendations of paragraph five of the
report
and
does the monitoring officer wish to
had anything at this point
no
okay i i think i was just uh checking
that you didn't need to
re-mention formally those amendments to
the report okay uh members um i i've
moved the recommendation as printed
thank you
thank you councillor smith do we have a
seconder
councillor wootton
are there any members that wish to speak
councillor wootton
madam chairman
none of us in this room i believe came
into politics to put up taxes and cause
our residents more expenditure
the reality of the fact is that out of
the six authorities we are the lowest
apart from i believe the essex fire
service
um
it is five pounds a year
for a band d property um a relatively
modest increase
but the reality is that that represents
two percent
the reality is
inflation is running at something five
six seven percent whichever indices you
choose to believe and rising sadly this
authority is not immune from rising
costs
and
i do urge the fact that when we look at
some of the authorities and the
necessary expenditure
essex county council of the order of 4.5
but a considerable levy in respect of
adult social care which we all
accept is posing pressures on county
councils so that when you pull that out
of the equation
their increases of the order of 1.99
exactly the same as ours
but they are the largest authority um
and they have the largest sum of money
uh but i would suggest that five pounds
um is very good value for money for the
services this authority delivers and i
stress once again
a budget that has been put forward
without cutting services it's about
vision opportunity and being an
innovative and creative council thank
you madam chairman thank you councillor
whitten
are there any questions
okay
council mr mason
[Music]
i'll be brief
we keep hearing about tempe
i'm sure most people in this room have
heard of jack monroe she lives in south
end
bootstrap cook
um
i'm sure most people are aware that she
did struggle
very much so with money and for cooking
um if you look on her
website you'll find that she survived on
meals which would costing 10 pence
10 pence could be a meal for many people
i
wish people would stop saying it's only
10 pence
that's the difference between a child
getting a meal or not getting a meal
thank you councillor
councillor mrs mason
thank you madam chairman i think
councillor hoy's taken almost the words
out of my mouth
there isn't any only
when it comes to families in hardship
slightly off the subject madam chairman
if you'll allow me i'd like to apologize
for misunderstanding the previous voting
but to facilitate
a speedy resolution of the meeting
i would ask that the item the
recommendations are taken separately if
that helps you thank you
mrs mason there is only one
recommendation and they are all set out
uh and
i'm sure you have already read it so
it's if it's okay with the members we i
don't intend to read out
every single point a
to
j
so uh
either
cancer fd
thank you
any more counsellor mrs
gladstone
thank you
um i'd like to start off chair to
thank um councillor simon smith and also
naomi and the team i found this budget
the whole report and transparent clear
easy to read and very informative
i feel the conservative administration
has sought through this budget
and in its proactive policy informing a
partnership with brentwood council to
maintain a high level of services and to
our residents whilst dealing with
growing budget pressures exasperated by
a loss of income caused by covert 19
also against the background of a
three-year settlement which although
fair will not be resilient against
unexpected
um increases in
inflation this conservative
administration has found extra money to
ensure that no family is negatively
affected in the 22 23 it changes the
housing benefit
in addition to dublin
council hardship fund and with our
government's 150 pound
um
grant to residents
and own when we say only i don't
um
dismiss the fact that 10 pence a week
can make a big difference
but i feel that as a administration
we've done everything we can
we need to remember that once you cut
the budget or take the money from the
reserves and you do not put up the
council tax unless i'm wrong you've lost
that money in perpetuity so that means
that when we then put our council tax up
next year we're always going to be that
162 000 pound behind which is then
creating a double deficit which we would
then have to carry so whilst i do
appreciate the concerns and i share
those concerns coming from a very
poverty background i do understand them
is that i feel that
we we can't lose sight of the fact that
we have to protect the council from
risks
of going into debt not providing
services so once again i would really
like to thank naobi and her team and the
conservative administration the members
that put this budget together because i
think it's fair its balance and it's
done its utmost to serve our residents
to the best of our potential thank you
thank you council gadsden
are there any more questions
councillor stanley
yep
thank you madam chairman um i'd like to
point out that the 150 pounds
for the government grant as it says will
be paid back over four years so it's not
actually a grant it's actually a loan
and as for the uh
amount of money that we may or may not
recover of this
160 000
um might remind the council that they
had spent 1.4 million on projects in the
past of which money has not been
returned to the kitty and 7 000 pounds
spent on the toilets
in crown hill which hasn't been returned
to the kitty either thank you
thank you councillor stanley
councillor smith would you like to
talk to your
sum up
thank you chairman um
after our item three united in the in
this item there are a considerable
number of matters of fact we can't um
really take issue with uh precepts that
have been set by other authorities
despite the fact that uh we have to
collect them um i i do understand what
council lahoy says in that it's perhaps
a an unfortunate term saying only 10
pence but i will just
remind members back to
item 3 where we specifically mentioned
the
increasing the level of the hardship
fund which was specifically to deal with
those
unfortunate cases and unusual cases of
hardship that
our residents may find themselves in
thank you thank you councillor smith
members there's the one recommendation
set out at paragraph 5.1 on pages 4.4
and 4.5 of the report
we will now move to the vote
though
those in favor
thank you members you may now lower your
hands
those against
hold on a moment
a microwave microphone's coming
sorry unless j is taken separately which
i will vote against
you're making me vote against
maths
i understand that most of it is
mathematics
but j is
council tax again which i've
i will vote against you're making me
vote against maths it seems silly
thank you councillor hoyle just
asked naomi lucas to clarify
thank you chair um
yeah just to try and clarify i mean all
the recommendations uh all the different
elements of the recommendation
are interrelated so they cannot really
be set taken separately because
one sort of begets the other so yeah
that you have to take them all on the
block
so those against please raise your hands
those are extensions please raise your
hand
that's 23 4 thank you members please
lower your hands
and nine abstentions
and that is carried
okay thank you members that is
that is all the business
for this evening
i will now close the meeting at
21.09 thank you